là il joue avec quoi on joue au rugby on
jouera quoi à bien des chiffres et
diagrammes d'accord un accord alors une
anagramme qu'est ce qu'une heure à g
vas-y c'est tabou composer avec toutes
les lettres dans l'autre bout d'accord
étaient mélangés et je vais te raconter
de bêtises sans labour
d'accord il fallait que je trouve
qu'elle est l'anagramme qui est un
prénom féminin
alors d'accord c'est une histoire
d'amour courte c'est une histoire de
kelly alors c'est un petit week end que
j'ai passé en irlande avec une amie
magnifique elle était rousse elle
m'apprit l'engrais et avec elle bien
j'essaie de faire au mieux mais j'avais
pas des scores extraordinaire je faisais
que 10 secondes mais comme elle était
rousse et qu'on s'instruit beaucoup avec
la rousse j'ai appris à parler en grès
et je l'appelais ma one lady quel est
son prénom extrait one one les doit
l'aider
les dix c'est quoi son prénom par les
hommes j'ai beaucoup joué au yoyo lambda
non alors ajouté hamas
c'est dommage et je reviens et je dois
dire c'est cette personne qui a perdu le
smartphone il m'a dit c'est bon allez
merci on arrête beinheim c'est qu'ils
s'étaient j'aurais plus je veux plus te
rencontrer et faire l'amour à la machine
car j'avais plus de rencontrer dans une
laverie car laverie égale valérie away
la nouvelle machine avant de chercher de
l'ormeau économique rob accueillir tout
cela n'envoie pas on va pas jouer avec
lui je crois pas non mais ils assez joué
dans sa vie bernard montiel
d'applaudissements
on va refaire le jeu glada grave il ya
smartphones à gagner pour la personne en
jaune la voilà la mer second jaune
d'accord quand vous appelez sabrina je
peux vous appeler l'ira saper la merci
allez vas-y bam étoiles à y aller mais
tu décroches la met en émoi dans l'est
alors j'aime bien me promener morgana
oui on a eu la chance fait le jeu de
l'anagramme on ait la chance c'est sur
le plateau de fait bien ou non et deux
oui c'est là on va parler un petit peu
de la mer parce que tu as la chance de
résider au bord de la mer
alors là c'est l'amour en mer a et on va
trouver un prénom féminin
maintenant c'est ouais c'est trop bien
sûr j'adore mais je n'avais imaginé vous
êtes sur un bateau merci par les flots
et c'est l'amour en mer a mobilisé les
fruits de la passion et tout d'un coup
qu'est ce qui m'arrive est bien fait pas
le mal de mer ah et on est obligé de me
rapatrier vers le port de plaisance le
plus proche soula valeureux plaisance
quel est le prénom d'un jeune fille kate
avec 60 à tout les ans à la gare de
l'essence quel est le prénom est ali
fille alors ça commence par un p bah oui
j'ai trouvé chef la c2 mtl c'est mon
sérieux alors qu'ils jouent alors il a
été beaucoup chauffer aux uv 1
c'est encore perdu dans le camp par une
bombe à la la la la la
alors attention c'est au tour de
christine kelly devenir qu'est-il
cadillac
[Applaudissements]
[Musique]
animatrice sinon on va jouer avec toi on
va jouer au féminin masculin
d'accord je donne des mots je demande
retrouver tu dois donner 10 bonnes
réponses en 30 secondes
est ce que ces mots sont masculins ou
féminins nouvelle affiche alors mes
toiles mettant la machine alors on n'est
pas chez nous ne serait là qu'est ce
qu'elle est belle c'est difficile je
peux à toi je peux regarder la pub
d'année les réponses je l'expliqué dans
un bassin artois en pleine fin c'est le
magnifique terre vraiment très stylée
j'avais une des plus belles femmes que
je connaisse il a dit non à bande
annonce on pas dit je n'ai pas dit que
je venais me suit une plume des plus
belles femmes que c'est le rêve oui
c'est qu'il est honnête j'ai dit c'est
magnifique a dit c'est quoi les réponses
attention attention à bien des maux qui
sont féminins d'autres qui sont
masculins me dit un wind d'accord j'en
ai marre oui on a parlé tout à l'heure
d'un diagramme alors doit-on dire un ou
une nana grave
non je n'ai pas à leur écoute perrin je
fais ça oui c'est une majorité running
interview ce que nous faisons à
convaincre les deux interviews l'un
l'autre
non il est préférable de dire uniquement
parce que c'est à dire les deux t-shirts
et des hémisphères émissifs à une
hémisphère et bien c'est un programme
tentacules c'est une température et bien
c'est un c'est pas grave
les brebis pour la route aller à garder
un vernis attention donnée pour la route
testicules ah bah oui joker en tout cas
ce qui est sûr c'est qu'on va tout
casser sur ce qu'on dit qu'une couilles
tu deviens une évidence et un ca de
garde une course à part alors l'issue
bien le combat ça tu dis oui ninon
aventure avec géraldine zannier
[Applaudissements]
et les siens là je pas qui je ne fais
rien il fait tout jean pierre jean kif
total vous qu'il fait les jeux enfin ni
oui ni non et je vais prendre quelqu'un
téléphone jacques tu vas toi mais tu
nous as dit oui ni non et si elles
gagnent et partira avec un smartphone
allez hop tout de suite quelqu'un qui ne
respecte pas la règle du jeu il ya un
fan oui pas de long dans vos réponses et
accès rapide et rapide top c'est parti
bonsoir comment ça va pouvoir terminer
alors été savamment d'été j'ai essayé
difficile mais aussi nos débuts très
difficiles le matin surtout procéder
pour sauver les matins j'ai un vrai
problème parce que le matin un énorme
problème dit oui là
[Applaudissements]
il est cependant pierre tu n'es pas
sauter les crêpes
allez on va regarder union qu'elle ira
même à mes débuts
charest
sur la tête de ma mère jean pierre
descombes il a vu kelly mon père c'est
comme quand tu arrives pour la première
fois au soleil kantari pour la première
fois à la mer avec des cas quand tu
perds mon frère il indiqué ouais bon dos
comment vos délires vous mes patates ah
bah écoute et bah j'espère qu'elles sont
chaudes thé pas beau tout au tout les
attaques attendant se demande cet écart
en ligne pour jouer au foot il est en
lice pour jouer avec nous dans une
seconde est pas une ça y est abilio la
floride allô allô alors dans trois
s'ouvrent des bombes a compté 3 2 1 est
basse et fini merci digne dans combien
de ces routes ça ça sonne oui on a
encore le téléphone technologies et 2018
les chiffres il ya le minitel aussi oui
j'aurais une bouffée de présenter jean
piat alors arrivé tout à l'heure j'ai
donné ses initiales hy mb allô allô allô
un nom alors oui oui oui ces 6èmes
d'inquiétant l'appareil clair salut
perds tu vas bien oui je fais quoi dans
la vie
pas grand chose à s'écroule pas bon au
moins ça nous fera pas comment les gens
tapent artois comm avec kelly également
bière tabbee tout y est dit à jurançon
jurançon je connais très bien
c'est à côté de ça oui voilà des mariés
étaient fiancés taille 9 par make la
personne à personne tu recherches coup à
toi comme neuf comme mec comme un
fichier d'accord déjà
[Applaudissements]
hi fi qui est d'accord bat un petit peu
comme nous un da par exemple dans
l'équipe c'est qu'il plus tôt style
géraldine valérie christine ou kelly ou
christine kelly kelly kelly ou christine
kelly donc eric ali ben écoutez moi tu
te bats votre bien alors qu'elle est
célibataire elle va être sur un dossier
comme et finalement ça s'est pas fait
enfin pour l'argent je vous explique
ouais j'ai des infos les vérités vraies
ou pas si voilà le dos et tombe à l'eau
dimanche soir exactement
allez les séries on va faire un windows
on va faire un érudit nos chers
jean-pierre ont rectifié sais pas ce que
je cherche l'amour le vrai amour et je
vois que c'est pas l'amour et ben voilà
là bas très bas mais calme-toi quand
même je passe mon chemin
mais c'est pas d'interview l'on n'est
pas dans cet abbé pierre
on s'oriente bien dans les yeux
attention c'est là où il faut répondre
[Applaudissements]
[Musique]
maxime jean michel mr bonsoir c'est mon
jean luc lemoine
alors allez on va faire un dernier dit
oui ninon avec la personne au téléphone
avec p r pierre c'est à dire vers chance
je vais on va perdre ni oui ni non on va
le faire avec maxime galy d'accord et
parce que jean-luc il est trop fort
jean-michel on comprend pas s'il dit oui
c'est tout sans moi mais un petit
problème à la cua tsinga dit cindy par
trendy ni oui ni non pendant rude au
milieu tu as tu fait de guizot bassorah
père ouais il va gagner plaire oui tu
sais ce qui se passera oui hier est ce
que tu mènes temps et aux riches
oui je suis là qu'est ce t'as envie de
gagner toi c'est quoi le cadeau qui très
plaisir on va déjà nous parler je suis
très content oh
[Applaudissements]
babacan hamon pierre donc on bat le
cadre on prend tout de suite quel cadeau
de téléphone est ce que tu veux gagner
un petit week end à pourquoi pas mal et
ça me fait plaisir
si longtemps c'est dans les mains et
dans la langue de maxime gagné face à
maxime au maximum mais car il ya un
week-end en jeu le patron c'est parti
bonjour bonjour il faut que tu peux
totalement calme ce qui est du ski vous
pratiquer de ski de la luge et des
cloisons
[Applaudissements]
l'essayer on essaye avait alors on
essaie avec jean michel adam étoiles à
mes toiles à mais il a déjà vu un mec
quand il joue à quelques soit derrière
lui je suis tout petit un mec qui m'a
fait part de ma part et jean-michel avec
85 alors c'est un maître card 85 mais
oui pour moi tu es un con mais ça
n'empêche pas s'il va très vite et très
bourg est gentil mais moi si ça vous en
dit pas je fais 162 cm non c'est pas
vrai bah tu content c'est déjà bien de
les avoir
attention pas nous y parvenons toujours
un on est prêt non bonjour bonjour
comprend si tous les matins pas assez
bon heureuse et mécanique engins
mécaniques mécanique jamais que les
permis de conduire
je les ai vu une voiture là je suis
content mais les mariés gelée était un
bon garçon célibataire célibataire et
des enfants dans des deux et quel sport
pratiquer le golf ou montage fans non
[Applaudissements]
les attentions à d'achat d'or aux
mondiaux on va faire un aller j le
garder à l'esprit que je sais que jean
luc c'est plus fort qu'ailleurs nouveaux
nababs jean-luc il imprenable bah oui
oui on faire du tout d'abord on va se
calmer quand même nom se trouvait qu'on
essaye avec teddy da ba oui mais non
marecek qui dit rêver actes et lycées
sont en frustrant
allez on lui a dit toujours toujours à
nous et que seul on est bien d'accord
que d'or pour toi bien qu'il y aurait il
ya un doute va bien parisienne où les
quais paribas n'est pas paris même jeudi
avec gmail était la preuve vous mettez
moi mais là on compte sur toi allez
pierre tu vas gagner un truc tu vas
gagner ce week end
attention ce n'est pas bon soir bonsoir
on sait déjà rencontré tous les deux
déjà mais on sait jamais gül mais
j'arrête d'être vilain rajouter les noms
[Applaudissements]